all right let's play a little what's
more likely divisional round style four
great games this weekend let's begin
with that browns chiefs game
what's more likely the chiefs get no
excuse me
the cleveland browns get a 10-point lead
at any point
or they trail the entire game what's
wrong man both of those could happen you
know what the last thing with that sami
watkins thing too like you might not
even play
this week what don't even comment you
don't even know if you're playing
i don't get that okay sorry wow
cleveland could get a 10 point lead at
any point we know that
they could also trail the entire game
i'm gonna go trails the entire game if
you make me pick either one
i am i don't you know i wouldn't be
shocked if they got out to a ten nothing
lead to start the football
game but i could also see
kansas city getting the ball first with
two weeks off and andy reid coming out
with some sort of attack
and and you know new plays and things
like that to where they jump out on
cleveland and never look back and not
that they blow them out
but cleveland has to keep pace that way
i think if you're going to make me pick
either one i'm going to take that one
i i do i agree with you i i think that
that you know andy reid now back in the
mode of getting ready
for the division around with a week off
ahead of time remember last year they
earned their week off week 17 when the
patriots lost and the chiefs won
and that that moment
however long it lasted it probably felt
like it was three weeks
of the texans building a larger and
larger
and larger lead and the season is
falling in
and what in the hell i don't think that
goes away
even when you come back and win the game
and win the next two
and win the super bowl that feeling in
the moment when you're down 24 nothing
at home
after two weeks to get ready for this
game that doesn't go away
and i suspect that andy reid and company
a big part of their motivation last week
and this week
is to make sure that doesn't happen
again so uh
you know what what juju was trying to
say last week they're gray nameless
faceless opponents to us
that's what the chiefs need to do they
they can't think it's just the browns
they can't think well it's not
it's not the ravens or it's not the
bills it's not the steelers or the
titans it's a team that everyone just
kind of looks at and says yeah
you can't you know i think the fact that
they went through
such a bad first quarter or so
and saw their season flash before their
eyes last year
i think they're going to be extra
prepared to guard against that this time
and
i love a good story and again i i i
don't want to see the chiefs exit the
postseason so early but man if the
browns are good enough to beat him so be
it i mean
i'm starting to get myself a little
fired up for the possibility of an upset
because that would be exciting
i just i i don't i i can't think of a
way that it happens
other than an exact duplication of what
we saw last week in pittsburgh where the
first snap
goes over patrick mahomes head and then
the brown
score a touchdown and even then i think
the chiefs are far better equipped to
come back from something like that than
the steelers were uh
me too i think the the you know the big
thing like we talked about in our pix
podcast right a little bit where
to me the big question with cleveland
you're hot on offense you're executing
at a very high level you move the ball
in whatever way you want
do you want to just continue to attack
on offense
and feel like hey we feel like we can
score with the chiefs
or do they try to like hey let's run the
ball and be like the cults last week
they did against buffalo and take the
clock down to two or three seconds every
play
and then play that angle i think that's
an interesting conversation because
they do have an offense that's that's
moving the ball at will
and you might not want to kind of break
your you know momentum there
you've been attacking aggressive scoring
points i think it's something to kind of
watch for when the game starts i'll be
interested to see how they attack it
what's more likely category from that
game what's more likely patrick mahomes
throws an interception or throws
for four or more passing touchdowns
chris
ooh if i'm picking one i'm gonna go four
plus passing touchdowns you know
the browns defense uh you know
it's not great in the secondary and
miles garrett you know with no olivier
vernon
i'm gonna go four plus touchdown passes
that's a lot of damn touchdown passes
certainly but it's not a lot for patrick
mahomes in kansas city really it's kind
of like middle of the road blah blah
blah
type of day so i'll go with that do we
have concern about
from the chief's perspective the return
of the cornerbacks denzel ward and kevin
johnson for cleveland no i mean that's a
huge
help for them there's no question you
know
that aspect of them being healthy denzel
ward is a guy
where you can say hey you go cover tyree
kill
you know you're not going to do that all
game long throughout but you could
certainly roll the dice
and say wait i'm not he's not totally
mismatched here so there is that aspect
of it and here's
another thing mike you know joe woods
that d coordinator for the browns
he was in san francisco last year he did
spend two weeks of his life
breaking down the kansas city chiefs for
the super bowl i would bet he has a
pretty good feel
of tendencies and things they like to do
and things he might take from that game
plan last year and apply it here
so that'll be something to watch for too
early on just to see how good of a feel
he has for this offense
the weekend begins on saturday late
afternoon with the
rams taking on the packers in green bay
what's more likely aaron donald who's
still a little banged up but he declared
yesterday he's healthy and he'll be good
to go
he gets two or more sacks or aaron
rodgers
gets three or more passing touchdowns
keep this in mind aaron donald had two
sacks in the wild card game
it was his third game this season with
two or more sacks and aaron rodgers
threw three or more touchdown passes
in 12 of 16 regular season games what's
more likely i i wouldn't be surprised if
like you know either one like both of
these didn't happen
i i i wouldn't i just want to say that i
think rogers and lafleur are very smart
they're going to have the offensive line
sliding the right way for aaron donald
to where he doesn't get a ton of
one-on-ones and things like that
and you know the thing i'd argue too and
pete maybe you can look this up
did anybody throw for three touchdown
passes against the rams this year
other than josh allen that that's where
i and that rams defense is better now
than it was earlier this year but
i would bet you other than josh allen
and that you know first quarter of the
season
i don't think anybody's thrown for that
type of output that's going to be
something to watch for if you're going
to make me pick one of the two which you
are because this is what's more likely
i'm gonna go with aaron donald who gets
two plus sacks i don't i don't see
rogers throwing three plus touchdown
passes in
this game with this defense no yeah i i
agree with you and i i
we talked about this in the pix podcast
yesterday will
jaylen ramsey even if he's blanketing
devante adams will aaron rodgers still
try to throw it into some little crack
some
opening that he may find in there but
you know aaron rodgers is unstoppable
he's the terminator as
sean mcvay said uh as it relates to
donald's ability to get ready and donald
said yesterday he's hoping
he hopes it snows there it is look at
that terminator will be ready
he said he hopes it snows but not too
much i don't know that other teammates
would agree with him specifically jared
goff if he's playing quarterback
but aaron donald ready to go he said he
hasn't played in the snow since he was
like seven years old
another one from that game on that
question of whether to what extent aaron
rodgers will throw the ball to devonta
adams
what's more likely two or more touchdown
passes for adams
or zero well okay and just to answer
that because pete looked it up did a
great job
uh kyler murray threw for three
touchdown passes and jimmy g they also
so that so it is doable against that
rams defense just to butt that
up i
i think i think i'm gonna go zero tds
here
you know i think i could see one
touchdown i don't know
the rams are really good they have in my
opinion the best corner in football and
jaylen ramsey
he is going to be in the face of devante
adams in some of these situations and a
lot of the times because they're so good
up front
they can play a lot of two safety
defenses and do that so
i'm gonna go with zero tds i can't
believe i'm saying that because like you
said
rogers and adams is one of those where
it's like oh you're you're covered
ah we don't care i'll throw a strike you
got great hands we'll still complete the
pass
but i'm gonna go zero tds what about you
i i uh uh pete just pointed out dk
metcalf had two last week
but but it you know you can i guess you
could have two it was a hard game
where you're being suffocated yeah right
right i mean it's a two that didn't
matter
yeah you assume that devante adam gets
two the packers are gonna win
um i'll go with two what the hell
it's not like we ever bring these up
five days later what the hell i'll go
with five who cares
but but how how the rams have changed in
two years and we saw this coming
when they trade for jalen ramsey that's
the indication
this is a defense-heavy team the offense
isn't what it was i i still don't know
why they gave jared goff 33.5 million
when you consider
where that defense is and where the
offense is but uh you know they're going
to have their chance this is not going
to be easy for the packers they win this
game they will have earned it
yeah i agreed and i think the rams match
up very well with them there's great
knowledge between these coaching staffs
you know mcvay and lafleur they come
from the same you know tree of coaching
all of that
you know so this is going to be very
interesting i expect a close game
i would be shocked and and to the snow
point with the terminator there who says
he hope it snows
yeah i'm i'm that way too i'd love to
see a little snow
you know to just make it easy on the eye
and look cool but i don't want
so much to know that it affects the
football game i don't want so much snow
that the rams who are one of the fastest
defenses in football if not the fastest
now have that taken away from them
completely and it changes the dynamic of
the game
i don't want that i'll say the same
thing with the bills in ravens game as
much as i'd like a little snow
i don't want so much that lamar can't
run and josh allen can't throw lasers so
i'm just hoping for just the right touch
there god can you please just give us
just enough snow
god to make it look good on tv but not
affect the guys on the field
the green bay forecast has adjusted
currently the highest 34 the low is 26
with a 51
chance of snow but it's all early
morning
okay uh between midnight and 2 a.m so by
kick
off it looks like it'll be low 30s and i
think
wind could be an issue let me check that
since i'm playing
part-time meteorologist while we're
doing this the wind is going to be in
the teens not
not hi the great one oh aaron rodgers
can throw it through the wind
no problem you you make a great point
though
we love a snow game
but not in a playoff game i mean i i
like the look of it but you don't want
some crazy lions eagles snow remember
that game remember there was a day in
2013 where like three or four snow games
all at once vikings and the ravens were
won
the eagles and the lions were one there
were a couple others there those were
the two worst
it because you you don't the best team
isn't necessarily going to win
under those circumstances you're not
going to see a great football game
because the offense knows where it's
going and the defense doesn't you you
are conducive to having a lot more
points being scored pete look up the
scores of those two games that day i
vaguely recall they were high scoring
but uh that was like december of 2013. i
i love a snow game
i like the look of the snow in the air
and and on the field but not so much
that it affects the game not not in
single elimination football
yeah no i i'm with you i i just you know
i want to see these teams at their best
i do
that's what i'm excited for more than
anything this weekend some cold some
flurries that's playoff football i'll be
very happy with that
well our game on saturday night has the
baltimore ravens going to buffalo to
take on the bills here is ravens
defensive coordinator
wink martindale on pressuring and
tackling
the guy who has become one of the best
quarterbacks in all of football josh
allen
you know he knows that there's there's
going to be pressure that's for sure
that's that's who we are that's what
we've done to me
tackling him you you better throw big
bodies at him because he's a big body
and and you know i told the defense
earlier we need to tackle him like you
tackle henry
because that's the way he runs
and i mean you're right you got you got
to get to him you got to get him on the
ground and
and we didn't see it as much
last week he had 90 plus rushing yards
in the playoff loss to the texans in the
wild card round last year at 54
against indianapolis he wasn't unleashed
the way he could have been i think
they're holding that back for when they
need it
and maybe they maybe they need it on
saturday night i i think they'll know
when they need it
right but until they need it let's just
work our offense our offense works
and you know we we talked in the megapix
joint podcast yesterday about the
possibility of the ravens neutralizing
staphon digs that may create a situation
where they need josh allen to run the
ball a little bit more
to keep those safeties on as to not
helping out over the top because you
never know when josh allen is going to
find a seam and just take off but
he's got the ability to do it both
quarterback backs in that game have the
ability to kill you with their legs yeah
i mean i these are two of the three best
running quarterbacks in the sport right
i mean really lamar jackson and kyler
murray you're going one and two
and i think realistically and please
correct me if i'm wrong here
i i believe just off the top of my head
josh allen is number three right i mean
that's at least the way i'm thinking
about it i didn't think about this great
deshaun watson right there we know that
but i think josh allen is three and you
know wink
you know he's funny i love how he's like
oh he knows we're gonna pressure like
yeah
they're gonna blitz they're the
baltimore ravens how much are they going
to blitz
that is going to be the big question you
better be careful
about blitzing the big guy big my boy
blue
he can beat you with bronze or brain
when it comes to the blitz that's where
he's scary
you know last week he oh wait you're
blitzing the free safety gonna do that
he blocked it up and got everybody and
bam 40 yard touchdown past stephan diggs
you want a blitz okay fine
you know but he also you could blitz and
get free and what i've seen all year is
he'll make the free guy miss and now
he's out on the edge
and you got one less guy to cover or
track him down running the ball
and that's where he gets dangerous and
and mike i think the interesting thing
about the matchup to me is just because
we've seen baltimore take this approach
against kansas city and it doesn't work
and this is the closest thing we got to
kansas city and football in buffalo up
there
quarterback the style of play everything
to where
you know i thought they got yannick and
gawkway to go wait when we play the
mahomes and josh islands of the world
we're not gonna we can't blitz all the
time and leave our corners on an island
against this group of guys in these
quarterbacks cause they're just gonna
make plays and there's nothing we can do
so that's where i'm really intrigued by
the match-up to see the approach by the
ravens
do they really blitz is winx setting
them up to go
oh yeah we're going to blitz we're going
to blitz and now we're going to drop out
and play coverage all game
i i'm really fascinated for the
different angles of this matchup
and you've got me thinking about running
quarterbacks here's my quick assessment
yeah
lamar jackson and kyler murray explosive
fast gone right right right
desean watson and patrick mahomes they
have more of an artful
sense of where the other guys aren't
sure there isn't that
that burst that you see from
from uh lamar jackson and calamari i
think josh allen's closer
to the to the jackson and murray duo
he's got that burst the watson and
mahomes because he's got the burst i i
think i'm well he i think he is number
three
right right yeah he's got some of that
he is he's just a he's a different
different way in which he moves then
you're right mahomes or watson who
kind of weave their way in and out of
traffic and
fade back and do all that stuff alan's
kind of just sit there
sit there oh you're getting close boom
i'm out of here either way
and you're right that's kind of more
like lamar and kyler uh but he's
dangerous and
and you're right that running aspect
even though last week you know he led
the team in rushing
it wasn't big runs where he's dangerous
is down in that red zone we saw him
score and touchdown right before
halftime right with that five yard run
you know that's where they put you in a
bind too
man they got a great passing attack man
they got these receivers we'd like to
double
wow we'd like to blitz him so he doesn't
buy time all day long and score
oh wait we gotta worry about the design
quarterback run game now we're one short
i mean they they really pose some
problems for you that offense down there
in that area
i remember when we all saw it for the
first time that bills were 17 point
underdogs in minnesota and josh allen
ran
right over through and around and
literally over hurdled anthony barr in
that game and we were like holy crap
this guy can run the ball pretty well
and they don't use it a lot
but when they do it's very effective so
to get to the topic finally after
talking about that
that was a good combo though it was a
fun conversation
what's more likely josh allen is sacked
three or more times
by the ravens or has three or more total
touchdowns whoa
i mean this is one i can certainly see
both of these happening wow
because i do think allen's going to get
sacked a few times in this game he's
going to buy time they're going to
confuse them with coverages they'll have
a few crazy blitzes that
you know that's going to take them an
in-game adjustment to get ready for
woo man okay i'm gonna go three plus
sack three plus times i'm gonna go sack
three plus times wow
i know i i can't believe i'm saying that
either but i could see josh allen having
two touchdowns and then maybe kicking
two or three field goals and winning the
game that way too
or somebody else gets you know the
running back
i don't know but baltimore's defense i'm
gonna go with the sax
lamar jackson what's more likely he has
over 100 rushing yards or under 50 for
the game
if out of those 136 against the titans
yeah
i'm gonna go over a hundred now they
played at the end of last year
and and i mentioned this on our podcast
you know what we talked about these
matchups really in depth
buffalo had a very good approach
to stopping the lamar jackson baltimore
ravens run game
now they let up a few big pass plays in
the game one was a long touchdown to uh
you know the tight end they traded down
there to the atlanta falcons hayden
hurst
but i'm gonna go i don't see
under 50 i mean under 50 is like almost
impossible i think for lamar jackson so
if i have to choose out of either one of
those i'm gonna go over a hundred
yeah i agree with you i you know the
over under was 77 and a half we talked
about that on the mega pix podcast and
maybe he's going to be in that golf i
think
50 and 100 but to choose between the two
i would take that one as well
all right the bucks at the saints the
last game of the weekend the epic battle
between a couple of
old quarterbacks here we go tom brady
has
three touchdowns no interceptions or
drew brees has three touchdowns no
interceptions what's more likely
i mean for the season and this is
amazing
in their two meetings this season brady
has two touchdowns and five
picks brees has six touchdowns no picks
it's it's it's the the ultimate show of
it's a match-up league i mean
it's it's not even close to who's
playing at a higher level i mean it's
tom brady it's disrespectful to even
compare them at this point
in my opinion brady is on fire
phenomenal you know they are doing
things that
you know only quarterbacks with a great
arm like his can really do on the
offensive side of the ball
but for this specific matchup i'll pick
drew brees
because i think brady and them again
it's aggressive passing offense they're
gonna have to win with him holding the
ball in the pocket and making big throws
that i think will lend itself to at
least one interception
brees on the other hand you know i think
they'll be able to kind of dink and dunk
their way
and he won't have to take those chances
yeah boy yeah i i keep going back and
forth and back and forth on this game i
still i
i i'll agree with you that brees is more
likely to go
3 td 0 int that that doesn't change my
belief
has articulated like a pig's podcast
that i think the bucks will somehow some
way pull a rabbit out of their hats
and also pull the heart out of the chest
of the saints and show it to them for
the fourth straight year where the
saints have
a mum devastating that's right
a devastating uh exit to the uh to the
postseason but
uh i'll agree with you on breeze hi i'm
mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports